Now let's talk about a Return Address Stack predictor
or RAS. We have seen that there are several types
of branches that we need to predict. For conditional
branches, we need to predict the direction. Is it taken
or not? And by now, we have seen a
number of predictors that predict direction reasonable well from these
types of things. If this branch is taken, we will
need to also predict the target address. And for that,
a simple BTB that just remembers the previous
target when the branch was taken will do just
fine because we always have the same target.
Another type of branches are unconditional jumps, function calls,
et cetera. As far as their direction is
concerned, it's trivial; they're always taken. So even the
simplest predictor of the direction predictor type will do
well on these. As far as the target prediction
is concerned, most of these either jump to
a label or call a specific function. So
simple BTB just remembers the previous target when
this instruction was executed will do just fine. So
it looks like we have handled both the
direction and the target for most of the common
branch types. However, there is a type of
branch, specifically the function returns, which is always taken,
so the direction prediction will do just fine. But
the target is often difficult to predict. If this
function is always called from the same place, then
the return will always jump back to the same location,
and in that case, the BTB will do fine.
But usually, we create the function so that it can
be called from multiple in the program. Something like
this, we have an instruction that can call this function;
somewhere else in the program, we have another
instruction that can call the same function. This
function has a return instruction, and now the
problem is that this return instruction should either
jump here or here, depending on where it was called from. The BTB, in this case,
will not do too well. Why? Well, because
when we call this and return here, the BTB
will remember that this is the target address. Then
we reach this point, call again, return. We should
be returning here, but the BTB is predicting this.
So, we have a misprediction. The BTB now will learn
that this is the correct target. Next, we come
back to this code again, and again, the BTB
is predicting here what we should be returning here
and then again and again. So, it never predicts correctly.
So the question is how can we predict returns accurately?